guerre 22 mois que les soldats sont au
front au contact avec les Russes aucune
issue ne semble se dessiner il faut donc
penser à renouveler les troupes problème
l'armée ne parvient pas à recruter
Emmanuel Chaz on vous retrouve en direct
de Kiev la question de la mobilisation
est au cœur d'une passe d'armes entre le
numéro 1 de l'armée et le président
Zelenski bonjour Julien effectivement
cette question de la mobilisation déjà
c'est un énorme débat ici au sein de la
société ukrainienne puisque ce des
hommes qui voulaient se battre et bien
ils se sont déjà engagés ça fait 22 mois
ou au moins au cours de la première
année de cette invasion à grande échelle
de l'Ukraine par la Russie tous ceux qui
étaient volontaires qui qui ont eu envie
de rejoindre l'armée l'ont fait alors
maintenant il s'agit de mobiliser des de
nouvelles troupes pour remplacer les
soldats épuisés qui se battent depuis
bientôt 2 ans le problème c'est que pour
se faire et bien il va falloir faire des
changements à cette mobilisation et que
le présid président Zelenski il y a
quelques jours avait affirmé que son
commandant chef des armées Valérie
zalouni lui avait demandé de mobiliser
500000 hommes supplémentaires alors sur
un pays de plus de 40 millions
d'habitants dont des millions jusqu'à 7
millions ont fui le pays à cause de la
guerre près de 5 millions de personnes
ont également été déplacées et bien ce
chiffre il est vertigineux sauf que
Valérie zalouni a expliqué lors de sa
propre conférence de presse il y a 2
jours qu' qui n'était pas en son pouvoir
de réclamer un nombre un certain nombre
de soldats qu'il participait en tant que
commandant en chef à des réunions avec
le ministère de la Défense en faisant
état de ses besoins en homme en matériel
et en équipement il fait également des
projections sur l'année prochaine pour
ses besoins puisqu'il faut compter avec
les pertes humaines et matérielles qui
ont eu lieu jusqu'à présent mais ce
n'est pas de son ressort que de réclamer
ce nombre au contraire c'est au
ministère de la défense de faire une de
formuler une demande au cabinet
ministériel qui lui va se référer au
parlement ukrainien la verhovna Rada qui
va décider si cette mobilisation sera
possible pour l'instant on parle de
baisser l'âge de la mobilisation pour
les hommes la mobilisation obligatoire à
25 ans de 27 à 25 ans et effectivement
c'est quelque chose qui fait beaucoup
parler ici puisque au sein de la société
ça présente une inquiétude pour ceux des
hommes qui n'ont pas encore été
mobilisés qui n'ont pas encore été sous
les drapeau un mot Emmanuel chasse sur
les combats est-ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que les positions sont
figées alors c'est pas tout à fait un
front d'un front figé qu'il s'agit mais
on voit que l'Ukraine résiste à cette
agression elle résiste contre finalement
toute attteentete puisqu'elle est en
infériorité numérique elle est en
infériorité également au niveau de
l'équipement face à une Russie qui
semble avoir un nombre infini d'hommes à
envoy voyz sur le front avec des
résultats évidemment catastrophiques
puisque les pertes sont immenses d'un
côté comme de l'autre les Ukrainiens
parlent de plus de 300000 morts et
300000 soldats russes en en incapacité
de se battre tout du moins on ne sait
pas quel est le chiffre des pertes au
niveau ukrainien c'est sans doute un
chiffre colossal en tout cas si on se
réfère au nombre d'avis de décès au
nombre de familles qui déplore avoir
perdu un fils un mari un frère on sait
que les pertes sont immenses les exp
également ce besoin de mobilisation mais
pour l'instant l'Ukraine elle maintient
en tout cas ses positions le long de la
ligne de front et chaque il y a vraiment
une bataille pour chaque mètre carré de
territoire on l'a encore vu avec marinka
que les Russes dont les Russes affirment
avoir le contrôle total marinka dont il
ne reste absolument rien seulement de la
poussière c'est le cas de toutes ces
villes qui sont disputées le long de la
ligne de front pour ce point Emmanuel
Chaz